Please welcome Devon Franklin.
Hello!
Hey, are you doing it's so good to see you.
It's so good to see you too.
And your beautiful wife was on the show.
Thank you so much for making it a family affair,
it was so wonderful to have Megan on the show.
Yeah, she enjoyed it.
She told me he had a ball
and she was just so glad that you had her.
So as a family, we say, thank you Drew,
we appreciate you keeping the door open for us.
I feel the exact same way,
thank you for letting me into your family.
I wanna ask you,
I actually put the first question,
basically from what the intro was saying,
you're telling us that we already have
the tools inside of us.
What are they, where do we find them?
I'm so curious,
I think that's such a powerful prompt for us humans.
Yeah. I feel that everything we need is never out there.
It's always in here.
A lot of times we're looking out there
trying to figure that out.
I was like, no, what's going on in here.
This idea of,
I talk about in this book about living free
and expectations it's all about starting here and changing
the way that we're looking at things.
Because if we're honest,
the hardest person that we're on is ourself,
and the moment we can change that perspective,
and that perception of who we are, everything around us
I believe start to change.
One of the thing I talk about this in the book,
when we get on the plane, they say, in case of emergency,
the oxygen masks will come down,
you put your mask on first and you help others.
Drew, I thought
first that was like the craziest advice ever.
I said, I would never do that.
If the plane was going down,
I would help everybody else then I'll put on my own mask.
And then I realized, if I do that
I might die by the third person.
But if I put my mask on, I can help the whole plane live.
So it first starts with us making sure
that we are happy that we're content
and then we can freely help as many people do
the very thing that we're doing for ourself.
Well, I get Oprah and her point now about, I mean
I always knew that you were so smart and
when our VFS heard that you were gonna be on the show
the questions just poured in.
Would you mind answering some of our VFS questions?
I don't mind at all.
Okay, great. Perfect. I love this so much, I'm so excited.
Our first video came in from Jean and she says,
that she's at a crossroads in her career.
Let's take a look.
I was able to get
on my dream career path fairly early in life.
But lately, it feels like I've hit a roadblock.
Seems like, everyone's passing me by
with amazing opportunities.
What can I do to hit the reset button
and get noticed by my boss,
or is it time for me to shift career paths?
What do you think about that Devon?
If she wants to move forward in her career,
she to not only meet the expectations of her job,
but exceed them.
And sometimes those expectations are unspoken,
and I talk about this in the book.
If you wanna keep your job, you meet the expectation.
If you want to get promoted, you have to exceed.
And you got to know what your bosses expectations are.
Don't worry about what your coworkers are doing,
don't look to the left or the right.
You look straight ahead
because you have the power to determine your course.
And too often, you looking over here,
and you're gonna miss it.
Jean, own who you are, find the power within,
know what those expectations are and go crush them.
Okay. Thank you.
We have another video from Kim who is ready for Mr. Right.
Hello, Drew and Devon.
I recently turned 40 and I thought I would be married
with children way before now.
I started dating a guy recently
and we have a lot of fun together,
but I don't wanna waste my time.
When is it appropriate time to ask, where's this going?
I am so excited to hear your answer.
You know, listen, I believe it or not.
I talk about this in the book.
Do not create
a false and unset expectation based upon your age.
Love will find you no matter what age
because sometimes we create that expectation,
Oh, I'm 40 and this has, or hasn't happened
and it creates an unnecessary stress
that we got to get rid of.
In this scenario, don't worry about your age,
but ask the question as soon as you feel
that this is the person that you wanna go deeper with.
Where is this going?
Once you know you are serious,
is one of the most important questions you can ask.
And whenever you hear the answer, listen.
Please do not mistake what they say,
because sometimes if you love somebody
or you really like them, they can tell you where it's going
and it's not where you wanna go?
And you say, Oh, it's okay, I'll spend some more time
with them and I'll get them in that direction.
No, if they're not going where you wanna go
just like you would get out of an Uber,
if it's not taking you where you wanna go,
you got to get out of the relationship
if it's not taking you where you wanna be.
Okay. That is a brilliant metaphor.
I really loved that.
Well, everything makes so much sense, Devon
and your amazing book: Live Free
is available
right now today.
Wherever books are sold.
Devon, thank you so much.
Thank you. Thank you.
And my best to your beautiful wife, Megan.
Oh, wow.
I'll give it to her, thank you so much.
Thank you so much. Thank you Devon!
(upbeat music)